my pretties morph our beauty pal proudly
present Dead Island oh [ __ ] I'm so lost
I'm on my way I know you need me I
really need you there's oh god this is a
big pool and this is difficult
where are you come or far I can't go
through the bushes but jump off the car
I love getting achievements why am i
such an achievement work I don't know
what yeah exactly
this feels good feeling lumen god
there's so much luthier I'll take that
and that and I'll take that and I'll
take that
whoa I got two of the big [ __ ] here
did you get a quest no I got a quest
wow there's so much loot money money
money
yeah but I'm a big dude hunting me
yeah I know but I'm busy [ __ ] sake
okay okay I'm coming
where are you Martha have you looted
everything maybe you need to get over
here dude I'm okay more fire there's two
thugs there I'm scared dude I'm busy I'm
busy looting I'm fine yeah baby oh my
god there's a lot of cash in the earth
[ __ ] oh my god oh my god shut up shut up
charge okay yeah sure I'll this is
really oh [ __ ] - yeah sure money money
money money
I'm clicking yourself - I don't give a
[ __ ] about again during the zombies
looting like a [ __ ]
that's kind of tells a lot of one's
personality yeah I think so too
we're never even supposed to go here but
there's like banks everywhere so I'm not
going to miss up doodie son Phyllis well
later on what
why the bags maybe we should go back
here this weapon zombies way out come on
they never stop I'm getting my fingers
getting tired yes we gotta be syringe be
able buy everything we want yes I want I
love my amp and I want a lamp yeah you
can one time to take Corsican no hm
of course you can then Oh kinda beer
okay you can have a teddy bear I'll have
it all time Walker
these [ __ ] never end what are you still
losing
oh [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] rich now mm I'm soon
but I lied I don't really have to solve
it okay hey you missed a callback so I
did not yeah then I'm thinking them I
left them yes okay where's our bags here
it doesn't even make any sense
okay the bags are gone that no there's
more hair
come on you pick them all right I can
hear one of the big guys whatever it's
money
my weapons are all worn out really [ __ ]
[ __ ] for now from Luna from killing
monsters yeah my weapon is worn out to
crap oh you got a reading this how are
you doing down there
it looks awesome on the mini-map wait
where the [ __ ] are you more far are you
in the hotel or are you go down the [ __ ]
it's awesome but it's nothing
this toilet was a distraction [ __ ] we
got here
oh god that's one of those what you ever
you call them I don't know
okay you'll just deal with them and I
don't know I have my two thousand oh
really
but I'm not done we are just getting
started [ __ ]
eleven ten from looting sweet
I'm level hey Oliver Thompson I think
I'm going for I need help
kits and then a lockpick to okay okay we
need to finish this quest noxious is
right here to do that and I'm almost
dying and my weapons are out of juice or
whatever you want to call it
okay go to where we're supposed to go
and we'll meet that super duper happy
took me oh I can upgrade my weapon ass
there's to brutes where we're supposed
to go I'm on my way I'm sprinting or
anything
I'm really really low hell I don't think
yeah there's no way to take place I was
looting like a [ __ ] earlier okay
what we need a plan and if we need to
pick up something I don't know really
these are looter for me okay that's some
gay but it depends if what man yeah yes
I got it one heads and I'm that by the
Italian if you understand one means like
like yeah you're there
yes perfect swing and they what I'm damn
oh I don't know you do something I'm
distracting yes I can they're almost
that no go oh wait maybe I can go Rachel
oh no I'm him
yes go rage mode oh that do that chillin
chillin yeah that was awesome
I forgot about that use the [ __ ] and I
got a crowbar so the quest is to go
inside here we really should repair or
something before but sure did you level
off to or what sorry did you level up as
well we're going in the hotel now this
is all some this games chapter 3 game is
get it gets better and better
I just got a phone call I need to shake
it well strong sure you take the phone
call is fine we need to find one of yes
but going through rooms and like try to
find valuable oh and you oh wait she's
like really disgusting yeah f---ing card
you
oh no no no I don't want to die out on
like I don't like is that you what's
with the music
I got a snack I'm crap you got the loot
oh whoa
it's punch kick perfect if you find a
sharp weapon yes must give it to me that
was oh oh he broke in half
what are you doing sorry are you
distracting my look thing oh wait I got
it is a bar here will she have like
surfing oh you [ __ ] Manchester facile
oh whoa what the [ __ ] happened it's fine
he dumped me I just got scared and I
need you sometimes it's all okay to use
okay we're going here yes no it's
probably buggy what's he saying I don't
promise you crap I find in the audience
it's cool okay we need to find a guard
named Ken and we go down here hmm
fancy badly don't yes yes we really need
a table we shouldn't spend so much time
looting and this is killing zombies
outside okay catch em Oh crowd a clue
maybe I can go rage ma no I mean I don't
know when I can go rage more
oh [ __ ] father feet secure yeah no hey
dad we're not your red kitchen remember
there's all be food here oh well I don't
know
I found soap that help like I looted yes
because I was oh god help me
ah now you're on your own needs fine
food false crap my weapon did ya what Oh
go down and stay down [ __ ] I'm super
focus right here like I'm on notice I'm
just looking around in but we have
cylinder and rooms are for the circle of
base yeah I wish I could arrange more
and no I can't I don't know even know
when I can you guys so when you oh [ __ ]
oh that's scare the crap out of me I
could hear that I'm just getting dumped
me I get some more health here yeah
that's that's fine I'll just kill this
guy out you don't have to do anything
oh you you on hiss
yes good let's rip them you need some
red [ __ ] one more hit and I'm down by
the way already
yeah come on more far where do you
respond oh [ __ ] I respond at the
Lighthouse no really oh good so that's
what I did
hey Kix is for are pretty good at these
guys but it'll take forever to kill him
[Applause]
I can't reach me if I kick out like you
are and I'll say why don't you remember
anything I next that they'll ever need
know where I am right now I respond
somewhere only visible aah cracking aah
we got a crowbar okay focus on my way
here I think I think it's yeah
good good he's nearly there get him boy
yes and my women just broke this is that
now yes he's like it doesn't work with
us anymore it's not here it's me what
why did you do that
again well there's so many of them the
bomb when we need it
yes sir the bomb what the only [ __ ]
let's take your egg skin kicker
yes now it's kicks it
I just kicked everything right now I'm
just trying to headshot them exactly
[Applause]
this no and it was a very hard question
so it's like oh my god oh that I want to
see again and thankfully I'm recording
hmm wait I got a weapon
Oh fine food here for sure oh no no no
no no no no no no no no oh oh holy [ __ ]
you go somewhere else don't be here
don't be here go go go
but I found lemon juice and alcohol ah
someone is hitting me oh there's so many
we're gonna die for sure one more friend
I need alcohol
and alcohol for oh crap it's a big guy I
can't do him I mean I'm really confused
where are you move for okay we have the
big guy left
I'm gonna take alcohol and then take him
we kick works great on him because he
can't reach you but it will take forever
tickling yeah yeah you can but you have
to stand far away your legs but all I'll
deal with a small bugger that
Oh No there's who are coming the walkers
here oh yeah oh yeah the walkers are
impossible I'm not God takes forever to
get the exhaust back yes we need it Oh
Oh Mike I hate when they sneak up aah
okay okay it's gone it's gone
why is there no food that guy is a thug
yeah
okay now probably this is [ __ ] we
need we need to repair our weapons yes
but we can do it come on
I got a snack it's cool we can we can go
pass him and then [ __ ] him [ __ ] him
let's go this can I throw alcohol no
crap let's go and here then yeah nice
format by the way yeah oh I think hey
don't you drink you take one if you need
do you need do you need what no no I'm
good take em it's fine
we're so bad at Arsenal fans and be
Williams Oh repair best people and we
have so much money I have
3,500 I have 3,000 now when I referred
to thousand and I will upgrade it oh
it's gotta be [ __ ] but green [ __ ] I have
okay from that now I have 1100 Oh my
blade yes oh this is gonna be awesome
oh this is awesome Oh everything is
instantly oh I see I see I see
I mean 6 & 6 what oh no I died died yeah
I didn't have much health so I lost 200
ah give me back my 200 families it's a
perfect place of my own G molest you oh
I see what it's on camera
I love cutting off their heads while
they're laying down so we're excited
about killing zombies and we've done it
for like I don't know oh I thought you
were a zombie sorry there's snacks here
if you want
I don't know this place is awesome we
got the loot we get there
oh my weapon is already won thank you I
probably saved that weapon for boss
fights and so I'll do something useful
yeah we should I have another blade
sighs okay here we go
it's been kicked I'm taking died that's
what I did
oh he fall oh he fell down high down
there it's so epic I want to do that I
wonder that wait who's so okay okay look
at this look at this look at this
no you're falling a wrong way get up go
down I'll give this family okay it's
this way
I just love it let me just pick another
finger should I go for wait wait wait
I'm in the tricky situation I'll
definitely go for a long big - so okay
I'm a team player right now no no it's
my look it's like if it's shorter it's
yours if it's blond